bonsoir alexis merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france peut-être un mot
d'abord sur l'homme un souvenir marquant
peut-être celui de la constitution
européenne dans ces dernières années
puisqu'il a toujours été l'homme de la
construction européenne il a mille euros
sur les rails il a été aussi il a oeuvré
dans le rapprochement franco allemand
avec helmut schmidt donc sans doute cet
engagement là qui marquera celui de
toute une carrière finalement de ce
président français quelle empreinte
laissera amélie giscard d'estaing sur
l'histoire des relations franco
africaines selon vous on en a parlé dans
le sujet précédent sujet très bien fait
parce qu'effectivement il était arrivant
au pouvoir
une promesse celle de la rupture avec la
françafrique il avait d'ailleurs et
l'ins et jacques foccart l'homme des
années gaulliste de la françafrique et
avait promis une coopération différentes
et de redonner de l'indépendance aux
états africains et puis durant son
mandat 6 intervention militaire de la
france et plusieurs opérations de
déstabilisation de régime aux comores au
bénin ou encore ailleurs et on voit bien
que les vieilles pratiques sont très
rapidement revenu avec de nombreuses
critiques les liens aussi avec l'afrique
du sud régime d'apartheid
là où valéry giscard d'estaing
souhaitait même intensifier la
coopération nucléaire pour vendre une
centrale à l'afrique du sud
et puis la sphère des diamants bien sûr
avec jean bédel bokassa qu'il a connu
lorsqu'il était ministre des finances et
qui a pourri cette fin de mandat donc
beaucoup de questions sur la façon dont
finalement la promesse n'a pas été tenue
beaucoup de communication ça a été sans
doute un des premiers présidents a
utilisé beaucoup la communication
politique à la fois dans la campagne
mais aussi dans sa pratique du pouvoir
alors la politique de giscard en afrique
était à la fois novatrice en rupture
avec charles de gaulle mais aussi
ambivalente complètement ambivalente
puisque il avait d'un côté le discours
scusez qui a été de redonner
l'indépendance des gestes aussi en
afrique du nord et puis la réalité sur
le terrain avec les opéras
son extérieur nombreuses et avec des
opérations également de déstabilisation
avec une sorte de reprise de soft power
à la française le français fabien sur
qui était la clé de voûte de ce système
post coloniale mais néanmoins où la
france gardait liens très serrés avec
ses anciennes colonies
sachant qu'à l'époque l'afrique ne
l'oublions pas été le nouveau territoire
d'affrontements entre l'est et l'ouest
en pleine guerre froide les troupes
cubaines débarquer aussi dans certains
pays et la france se faisait le bras
armé des états unis qu'ils se
désengageaient des théâtres d'opérations
extérieures après l'échec cuisant au
vietnam et c'est d'ailleurs alexis
l'afrique qui a pesé on lisait sur la
présidentielle de 1981 l'image de
giscard d'estaing était entachée à ce
moment là complètement avec cette
fameuse affaire des diamants du
dictateur jean-bedel bokassa diam
affaire révélée par le canard enchaîné
où il aurait reçu plusieurs fois des
diamants de plusieurs dizaines de carats
de la main même de jean-bedel bokassa
lors de ces parties de chasse en afrique
parce que valéry giscard d'estaing était
friand de safari et de chasse en afrique
et la à divers occasion il avait reçu
trois fois plusieurs diamants dont le
montant reste
mystérieux malgré les annonces du canard
qui parlait de plus d'un million de
francs celle là était contestée le
président valéry giscard d'estaing avait
dit qu'il avait redonné ces diamants
dans le cadre des musées de la
présidence ou bien pour des oeuvres
peut-être que c'est le cas mais
néanmoins il a perdu et ça a pesé lourd
dans sa fin de mandat face à françois
mitterrand en 1981
et beaucoup de questions restent sûr
bien sûr ces diamants et les la
proximité avec jean bédel bokassa qui
l'a soutenu jusqu'à la fin sauf quand le
responsable africain a tué plus d'une
centaine de jeunes écoliers et là il est
passé du côté bien sûr de la
déstabilisation pour démettre l'empereur
autoproclamé qu'était bokassa alexis
voulait un peu plus communément giscard
d'estaing c'est évidemment le divorce
par consentement mutuel mais aussi
l'avortement légalisé avec simone veil
évidemment oui il a accompagné les
changements de société il a acté la
victoire des luttes féministes
donc il a pu faire ces lois là
puisqu'elle qui était demandé tout
simplement par l'évolution de la société
et aussi par ses années de lutte
des féministes qui ont obtenu gain de
cause mais c'était quelqu'un qui restait
quand même sur laser puisqu'il n'a pas
aboli la peine de mort il a laissé des
condamnés se faire décapiter les
derniers décapité a était encore sous
son mandat il a également continué de
faire de l'homosexualité un délit il n'a
pas enlevé la loi qui faisait de
l'homosexualité un délice est arrivé
beaucoup plus tard donc une avancée
mais pas un progrès énorme il était
simplement là au bon moment pour acter
de la victoire de certaines luttes et
heureusement il a fait les lois qui
allait avec
c'est aussi ce qui lui donne cette image
de progressistes qu'il a eu à l'époque
puisque c'était le plus jeune président
élu et qu'il avait utilisé les méthodes
qui avait permis à kennedy de se faire
élire il avait même invité un des
conseillers de kennedy pour faire sa
campagne et cette communication où il
s'est mis en scène avec la vie privée
l'accordéon il s'invitait à dîner chez
les français tout en cachant la partie
de beaucoup plus luxueuses d'aidé safari
africain des chasse en sologne et ses
débuts à l'âge de 48 ans mercy alexis
poulain en direct donc sur rt france